i don't know whether i'm going to put it
out or not but i did write a song that
i'm proud of that i really like a lot
for my son and it and it's honestly just
you know it's not a song for the radio
it's not that kind of stuff it's just a
a song that i wrote for him that i'll
i'll hopefully record and maybe
have for him one day when he can
understand just so i can say i wrote you
a song before you were born about
you know how nervous i was to have you
all that kind of stuff
congrats on your new music your new song
fill them boobs is out
now
[Music]
how does it feel to have new music out
now for your fans
oh my gosh it feels incredible i have
been
waiting to put out new music for quite
some time and um
you know when i returned with music i
wanted it to be
up tempo fun feel like summertime
and praying that i accomplished that
with building boots
i think you did you have more
new music coming for the fans what has
been the biggest source of inspiration
with this new batch of music
yeah um you know what obviously my
wife's pregnant now we're expecting our
first child
um so i feel like i've got a whole new
set of inspirations but um
building boosts was a song i actually
wrote two years ago
of when i was out on my big big plans
tour it was one of those songs
that i had a chance to listen to the
demo you know for the last
year and a half two years ever how long
this been and
it never got old and i felt like that
was a pretty good sign so i decided to
uh record it and and get it out there
and now i've got a whole
new wave of music coming um that is not
gonna be
a record okay uh you know i'm gonna stay
flexible and nimble that way if i write
songs that i really love a lot i can
jump into the studio
not necessarily be tied to a project
right now and i can just kind of
put them out there as i see fit that was
my next question is like is there a
vault of new tracks that you were
gearing towards you know an album but
you're kind of just
going with the flow of things right now
i think eventually they may morph into
an album potentially but um
i love the idea of being super flexible
and putting out things whenever we feel
like it and whenever we want
because you know putting out a record
like i mentioned it's been three years
since my last one and
uh you kind of get tied it down to that
for it let us
run it cycle um which makes it super
hard to be patient you got to be
incredibly patient to do it that way
so i love the approach of just coming
song by song whenever we want
and putting out an album is like you
know you got to treat it like a baby
it's it's your it's your baby and
you you got an actual baby coming you've
gotta have
us your priority right now right yeah oh
my god i'm so excited for it so
nervous uh for that moment in my life
but
uh so ready you know i grew up with all
boy cousins and obviously i have a twin
brother so
um i prayed hard for a boy first time
around my
my goal is to turn him into a pga tour
star
but i know lauren also wants a girl and
and uh we're gonna pray hard for that
after we
kind of get our feet wet with with the
first and and uh whenever that time
comes
a couple years down the road we'll we'll
hopefully have a girl one day
you said you're nervous why you're gonna
be such a great dad you're already you
know you're you're used to being uncle
chris
you know what makes you nervous for this
yeah you know what
um i guess i did get my feet wet being
an uncle you know my twin brother
has a 10 year old now which is insane to
even think about
but um the dif the difference is this
time you don't get to give them back
after you're
uh after you're done playing but my
brother says
i've heard quite a few people say this
but he always tells me he's like man
you don't understand right now but
you're about to experience a love like
you've
never had or known in your entire life
and uh i'm ready for that moment who do
you think is gonna be
more of the waterworks in the delivery
room you or lauren
um definitely lauren i wouldn't say i'm
i'm an emotional guy
but who knows maybe i maybe i will i
said i wasn't an emotional guy when i
was getting married and i somehow ended
up crying during that which was
sort of embarrassing but at the same
time it's uh yeah
it hit in the moments real so so who
knows maybe i will but
i can definitely envision lauren being
the water works
hey because she's had to carry him
around for
this whole time and um i'm sure she's
she's ready to see him face to face as i
am
what type of father do you hope to be
and do you think you'll be do you think
you're gonna be
more strict than lauren um i would say
i will definitely be the strict parent
however it has been
a little bit of the other way around
with the dogs at this point i feel like
lauren's the more strict parent but
i think the way i think about it is the
dogs can't talk back and really
understand or at least i feel like they
don't truly understand what i'm saying
with the child you can correct them and
they
understand um so i feel like i'll be the
stern one when it comes to that in fact
we've had many conversations
lauren and i have about which one's
gonna be
that parent and and you know what with
it being a boy i feel like
as as his father i'm gonna have to be
the one who steps in
and i have no problem doing that my dad
was that way i feel like i learned from
him my whole life
and um you know the thing that i love
about my parents is the fact that they
were there for
everything my brother and i had i mean
from when we were kids
every baseball game football game
basketball game whatever it was
even when i got into college you know
they never missed a game and
uh i definitely want to be there for him
in the same exact way you'll be a
present father but you'll also lay down
the law
i will lay down the law lay dog a lot
you and lauren are
in year two of marriage now how would
you say pregnancy
and a pandemic has made your
relationship stronger
yeah honestly i feel like it truly has
brought us even
uh closer and i know there's there's
times that um
we need a break from each other more so
her away from me but
um we've also had to be super careful so
we haven't really
had a chance to like go out on dates and
go to restaurants and stuff like that
just for her sake so
we we've we've really just been at home
for
for so long it's given me a chance to
get out there on the durham grill and
cook some stuff up and help out in that
way but um
yeah i mean spending a lot of time
together uh
i think could go one way or the other
and for us i think it's been an
incredibly positive
uh positive thing that's great to hear
and once baby boy lane arrives and
you do want to head out on tour i would
imagine
you're itching to get back out on the
road for your fans are you gonna round
up the troops the dogs the baby
lauren everyone's gonna hit the road
yeah yeah i think this year
uh lauren will probably sit off from
doing too many shows
just so she can be at home with the baby
however i may not even end up with that
many shows at the end of the day
i'm just kind of sporadic here and there
until i start out with kane brown back
or when we jump back out in september
but um but yeah
she may not come out right away but uh
probably next year
you know we'll bring him out there um
when we can
and when it seems like it would be a
good fit to do so i'll have to get a
a bus made with a with a crib and and
all that kind of stuff which would be
exciting it's a good thing you have
friends like kane and and all the other
guys who have babies now
that can kind of give you a little
insight and all that but isn't it crazy
the way
that timing works because you know how
this had happened before the pandemic
you're used to being on the road every
weekend and leaving and now it's
different you actually get
to stay home and kind of enjoy this time
with your new baby that you probably
wouldn't have had before
yeah it's true and even in the the
process
of trying to have a child um you know it
took us a minute for for it to
actually happen and i think a blessing
in disguise
whether we knew it at the time or not
was it it really did give us a chance to
truthfully try for that you know coming
off the road
every weekend is is exhausting when you
get home
and sometimes stressful but but we're
also incredibly lucky to do what we get
to do but um yeah
it gave us a chance to to honestly try
for that
it happened and and now be able to
100 be there for uh the birth and and
be there that whole first month that uh
he's just born
it's funny because the last time you and
i spoke was at the beginning of the
pandemic
and you two were talking about how you
were using that time
to you know work on having a baby
and i feel like you've had the most
productive pandemic you
you made a baby and you made new music
yeah i tried to use my time wisely um
that is for sure it gave me it really
gave me a chance as well to sit down and
try to write every single day which
which i never did a lot of
before this just because in a young
artist's career you're constantly
whether you're out there playing radio
shows during the week and then you're on
shows on the weekend
um it's a lot and you're not at home a
lot
so uh you know on those one or two days
off you may get a week
they're usually not off you're trying to
write but it's hard to write when you're
exhausted and
i feel like i'm getting some lifelong
material
that i'm super proud of and can't wait
for people to hear
would you say the creative juices are
flowing more now than they ever have
been in your career
yeah 100 um and i think it took me
getting in the writers room every day
to i think pull my best writing out
um it's honestly it feels like a muscle
that you once you get in there and start
working out
it just it becomes better and better
every single day and
i've kind of discovered a lot in my
artistry
through uh through the writing process
and being able to do it every single day
opposed to
once or twice a month you know are you
writing any lullabies yet
no but i will say this uh what i don't
know whether i'm gonna
put it out or not but i did write a song
that i'm proud of that i really like a
lot for my son and it and it's honestly
just
you know it's not a song for the radios
none of that kind of stuff it's just a
song that i wrote for him that i'll i'll
hopefully record and maybe
have for him one day when he can
understand just so i can say i wrote you
a song before you were born about
you know how nervous i was to have you
all that kind of stuff
uh have you played it for lauren's belly
have you played it for him yeah honest
honestly when i when i play demos and
stuff in the house or or
when i played feeling boots and summer
job money through my speakers in my
house
i'm not joking he always starts moving
in her stomach
whether that's coincidence or not i
think it's pretty cool
honey i know you said that you wanted
him to go into the pga
but uh i think he might be a musical
baby
yeah you never you never know i'm gonna
push him the other way though